couples kissing in public even same-sex
couples and they drink beer without
anyone objecting that only happens in
Izmir says filmmaker Kasim cousin he
tells us his hometown has always been
different from the rest of Turkey the
other part of it is to Martha zakat
we've never had a mayor who belonged to
a right-wing party that has a lot to do
with the tolerant and relaxed political
climate here is Mir is on the Aegean
coast with a population of 4 million
it's Turkey's 3rd largest city and
perhaps its most European this is due to
the port city's location as well as its
multicultural history says cousin
[Music]
over a hundred years ago Greeks Italians
Brits and even Dutch people lived here
in this neighborhood
this wasn't just a hotspot for trade art
and culture thrived here too
the pro-kurdish Peoples Democratic Party
or HDPE can openly sing pro-kurdish
songs on ferries like this one many HDPE
members are in prison elsewhere its
rallies have been attacked or banned but
in Izmir the ruling AKP moves their
stand to make space for the opposition
party and the police stay back looking
relaxed this could only happen in Izmir
Qasim Puzzle is amazed to see parties
which were once bitter enemies stand
side by side across the country for
opposition parties have joined forces to
prevent the re-election of president era
Wong the main opposition CHP the
Nationalists EU Party the Democratic
Party and the small Islamist Saadat or
félicité party sauna debt supporters in
particular are not accustomed to working
together with secular parties we're
going to be living together so why not
cooperate now for the future of this
country Kasim cosa would not vote for
any of them but he welcomes that they
work together to resist the looming
threat against the country's democratic
system
okay it's not mutual affection that
brought them together but the common
goal of preventing the planned change of
our political system is mere will remain
progressive no matter what happens
States Semih guru the teacher only
learned to ride a bike as an adult now
she helps organize the fancy women bike
ride movement once a year thousands of
women from all over Turkey wearing
shorts or summer dresses join her in
Izmir and ride colorfully decorated
bicycles through the city
[Music]
babies trawl the picture we've grown to
be so many that now the city government
is asking us what can we do for you
that's a huge success for us because it
shows we've managed to get transport
policymakers to communicate with each
other cuz all fears women will no longer
play a part in shaping ismir's future if
air21
is reelected some joke that if that
happens the city will have to become
autonomous no matter what happens we
will do all we can to defend the
freedoms we've gained
his hope is that the newly-formed
opposition party Alliance can win back
the whole country just like in Izmir